folks folks folks happy halloween
they're a little early but the whole
month of october is halloween first i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by amc plus
and the walking dead and the walking
dead's been a wild ride for me i was
here on youtube talking about it when it
first came out now i'm here talking
about it as it reaches its end game but
a wild ride for me meeting some
characters that would become favorites
that some started out as villains that
scene that intro of negan with the whole
eenie meenie miney mo thing that is a
solid 15 minutes of television tension
right there which makes his flip from
villain to anti-hero one of the more
unexpected elements in recent walking
dead for me it's the end of an era and
it being the beginning of the final
season anything's possible which makes
me very interested predictions carol's
going to survive us all
she has to you can catch the part 1
finale of the walking dead early on the
amc plus app using the seven day free
trial just click the link below and
thank you once again to amc plus for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
and now more squid game why because
after i did my review people are like
sweet spoiler talk please and this is
exactly how it went down i kid you not
after my dad and i watched it i'm doing
my video my dad immediately restarts
squid game and watches it in its
entirety again back to back and after a
second viewing he skipped all the games
to watch the games for the [ __ ] of it he
loves squid game i also appreciate your
support in the comment section sorry
this is the squig game spoiler talk
spoiler warning again i say spoiler
warning don't watch this if you haven't
seen squid game even if you're like i
don't think i'm gonna see squid game you
will eventually so don't watch this
because you want that marble game to gut
punch you we all do it's our way of
feeling something but as always i always
say my spoiler talks like oh this isn't
gonna be a play-by-play i'm not gonna go
like scene for scenes step by step squid
game i really want to but it's just i'm
not going to there will be things i
forget to talk about and things after i
upload the video i'm like [ __ ] i wish i
talked about that don't worry there's
always going to be more talk about squid
game for my video of squid game season
two which is definitely happening so how
people get roped into this game is this
slap game you know it's like you slap
the paper on the ground you got to flip
the paper and if you don't it's like oh
you got to pay money or you can pay the
the body price it's like slap okay you
pay with a slab you get slapped which is
really manipulative and kind of amazing
because you know that you will get the
money that you promised and you've just
spent however long subjugating yourself
to this person so on many levels you're
probably going to be like yeah here i
come to the game and when you watch
squid game again for your second viewing
there are things that you'll notice
that you didn't notice the first time
around or maybe you noticed it but it
didn't stand out like in that first game
red light green light when people are
you know dying and then it gets to the
point where people are crossing the
finish line you see the old guy number
one he's like yeah big grin on his face
crossing that finish line like he's
grinning like he's having the time of
his life he's grinning because he's he
is having the time of his life because
it's his game that's that's the thing
that's the big twist is that he's the
guy behind it all in that second viewing
you see his big old grin you're like oh
man i don't know i just the first
viewing you kind of take it i was like
oh he's an old guy
i don't know what i was thinking i don't
know why i wasn't like wait a minute why
is he grinning at a point in the series
you're like oh he has these intermittent
moments of being lucid not being lucid
maybe that was just a moment but it's
not he's just super happy that he's
playing life and death with people i am
a little bummed if i'm skipping forward
because i mean now we're talking about
second viewings i am a little bummed
that when the guy you know like
what's his name the handler
i don't know what his title is the super
scary masked man the front man i think
that's what they call it when you know
he's asked like why are you doing this
and he's like you bet on horse races to
us you are the horses i kind of wish
they didn't explain that to the audience
you know because on second viewing you
could watch him betting on horse races
and it'll just hit you like oh he's
better than horse races to them their
horses oh wow you don't mean any more to
these people than the horses mean to you
that's super dark but you know it would
be a thing that would mean so much more
if the audience just reaches that
conclusion upon second viewing and one
of the coolest things in the show
is the thing that makes the second
episode slow down but it's really
necessary is when they take that vote
like yeah if the majority votes to get
out of here the game will stop and it's
a tied vote and the old guy is the last
vote and he actually votes like yep stop
the game let's all go home which is
amazing because that's how certain he
was that people would come back which
also shows he's like well i want people
to play the game
if they want to play the game seriously
have you ever
tried to make someone play a game they
didn't want to play it sucks yeah point
is people walk away and a lot of them
are like
what's out here
why not have that shot also brilliant
move on the company's part aka the old
man's part and having the big
see-through piggy bank above everybody
continually reminding them why they're
staying there and squig game has more
than a few important moments there are
these moments that are just kind of like
checkpoints for me where i'm like that's
a very important moment that takes it to
the next level one is when there's an
unofficial game that's still part of the
game where they give everyone very
little food
just to cause just to stir the pot and
then of course a fight breaks out so
they can find out who's the alpha chad
that guy which is interesting because
that's when you learn like wait you can
just beat someone's ass to death and
it's not really against the rules i
guess all right so we need a team of
assassins to stealthily sneak around in
the night and just kill people in their
sleep but that's when i was like high
school cafeteria elementary school
playground it's all this that's all life
is everything you need to know to
survive life you learned on the
playground but a big landmark moment in
this entire thing was the tug of war
game that was
when it really got real for the
characters for me at least in my
perception because it's the first game
where people died
based on you like
you're winning means they die before it
was like you could cross the finish line
if someone else died it's because they
moved during red light green light if
someone else died in the candy game is
because they didn't cut the shape out
fast enough or they broke the shape
before you living and them dying those
were separate things but in tug of war
if your team won it meant the other team
died it means you killed them that's
probably when it got much more real for
these characters the marble game is
that's just when we all cried i mean
everybody cried you know it was just
like oh we have to team up in teams of
two and that's when our lead is like
the old guy
i'm gonna be on his team funny because
old guy knew that the world was well
even if you don't find a teammate in
this round it's not like you die then
the reveal was yeah teams of two in the
words of optimus prime one shall stand
one shall fall one eu's gonna live when
he's gonna die that got real for
everybody because all of us were like oh
man the old man's gonna die because i
mean the main guy is not gonna die
husband and wife are looking at each
other that [ __ ] was brutal what dude
completely swindles i was like this is
the most naive human ever couldn't the
majority could vote right you know the
majority could vote during the game
because at the very end
of the show in the very last game he's
like no if we can take a vote if me and
him don't want to go on the game can end
like yep that's true okay so when
husband and wife are like we don't want
to kill each other and the dude with the
old guy are like i would no i don't want
to do this if the majority of the people
who you have to assume teamed up with
people they generally like
they could vote like nah nah let's not
do this i was actually really surprised
nobody threw that out there but i
suppose if they did that then there
wouldn't be
what the show's going to end there
regardless most trusting human on the
face of the planet dies
because it got swindled because dude
it's all about technicality as a magic
the gathering player myself it is all
about the wording and i did appreciate
that fact where he's like the rules
state i can use any means necessary by
any rules just don't resort to physical
violence to get my opponent's marbles i
did not resort to physical violence and
i have his marbles meanwhile toodles
have still lost his though i was like oh
[ __ ] when the main dude is playing
against the old guy eddie's basically
the old guy i mean he's playing up
dementia but we don't know that at the
time and our lead realizes that he can
just tell the guy oh no you said the
other thing and he would believe it
and so he starts doing that and you're
like this is brutal in so many cases in
the marble game people
realize how ugly they have to get
or
how ugly they're willing to get to get
the money the only person who didn't get
ugly were the two girls are teamed up
and that one drops the marble like oops
slipped it's like
that's
they were all brutal in their own way
like they're all just gut-wrenching
heartbreaking scenarios but i broke my
own rule my rule is if you don't see the
body they're not dead which means the
cop is alive for season two absolutely
we're not we didn't see the body now i'm
not falling for that [ __ ] again because
i fell for it with the old man i just
thought it was like well no one wants to
see an old man get shot in the head
which is true but they used that to hide
the fact that the guy didn't actually
get shot he didn't die because he's he's
the mastermind when the game of glass
hopscotch whatever it i don't know what
the game is called it's basically two
panels of glass they're up on this
high rise and they're like 16 to 20 rows
of glass
side by side and one is tempered glass
that'll hold your weight and the other
one's just regular glass and you're
gonna fall right through have fun
guessing yeah i was like there's no way
we're gonna leave this game with more
than a couple people this is that's the
thing i appreciated about the show is
that they did a good job at having games
filled with tension as the games went on
i was like no no we're really slicing it
by half here tug of war was the first
one where it's like the survivors down
by half marble game down by half the
glass tempered glass game down by a lot
more than half i love the guy he was the
math expert the mathematician he was he
just starts going through it he's like
the odds are one in 30 something
thousand he was the one who was smart
enough to know how [ __ ] he really was
he was like
screw it he just starts running i mean
what can you do you know i was like what
are the odds he said the odds they're
not good this is also when we meet the
vips with their cow head masks and
whatnot and yeah
these are the bad actors of the movie
like they're definitely the weakest part
there are a couple of plot lines that
were interesting but then they're just
gone at a point you know like the organ
harvesting thing it was just it was
happening and then it was gone granted
they all got sniffed out and caught and
it led to problems and i liked how it
showed that even the enforcers or they
have their little thing where they're
trying to chip away and get a little bit
more money showing that they need more
money showing that they're not well
taken care of they're not free
everyone's a slave to the system so the
cop looking for his brother who ends up
being the the company man the front man
the ominous masked man and then the
final confrontation the final game after
they all got steak dinner and our girl
got boba fetted she didn't have to i
mean she was probably going to die which
i do call foul on that like all right so
the glass
platforms they all blew up and a shard
hitter really big shard too i feel like
you'd be like dude that i passed and
that thing blew up and this is kind of
your fault you should fix me i mean it's
not like you're dealing with the most
sensitive people but they do seem pretty
stringent on rules being important and
i'd be like the rules say i passed and i
shouldn't die as a result of passing i
shouldn't die as a result of
your pyrotechnics after the game was
over after i was declared a winner of
that game so come on patch me up but she
was going out she was going down and
then
dude there's dude's friend like
she just gets her throat slashed i'd
have been pissed too i'd have been like
what was she a threat why'd you do that
like if we're all playing the next game
she was on her way out if she lived to
make it to the next game you think she
was really gonna be able to do anything
but it puts our guy in mode where he's
like offense on squid game and squid
games just seems like i don't know squid
game myself i never played it that was
not a thing we played on the playground
the duties would send you to the wall if
you tried to play a game like that a
good epic and odyssey is not without its
poetry and so it it's a face-off between
two childhood friends he has a face off
against his his childhood friend cho
sang woo in which cho sang woo gets
beaten and then it's thrown out there
like hey if we both
vote to stop the game the game can stop
and then his childhood friend cho sang
woo stabs himself in the neck which is
sad and it sucks but it makes sense to
me
um because
option one is yeah they do end it but
then the money goes to neither of them
it goes to the families of the people
who died which isn't a bad cause
but it's not either of their cause
definitely not his cause so i think he
kills himself knowing
that his mom will be taken care of so
our lead gihon has the prize money and
he just kind of never uses it and this
is the reveal when he goes and meets the
old man you know his his old friend was
the phrase his ganbu
you know
what a sweet old man who manipulated and
caused the deaths of a lot of people but
damn it what a sweet old man and he
really just kind of makes the point of
it all boils down to money doesn't buy
happiness it reminds me of a phrase that
i'm not gonna front i heard it from i
believe it was civilization six because
i have sean bean's voice in my head when
i think of it money can't buy happiness
but it can help you
to live comfortably in misery or
something like that i always like that
but i think
there's
the relatability of this entire story is
the fact that
i think we all understand what it is to
be an adult and want to be a kid again
or at least have that connection that
fulfillment we had when we were children
when you're a kid you want to grow up
and be an adult when you're an adult
you're like i could really go for those
simpler times when playing with friends
was completely fulfilling so what do we
do we buy retro games and we build
nerd caves and nerd rooms to feel a
piece of that again you get money to
spend money so you can try to feel that
connection
that you felt when you didn't have money
but i love it i love the story i love
the characters i love the concepts i
love the layers i'm still appreciating
this series as i think about it
and upon second watch i imagine i'll
catch more and i'll think about more and
i'll think about oh what it's saying
about money and happiness and connection
and life that's what i love about
stories like this alright so again squid
game now you can talk about spoilers
below and talk about all the things
spoilerish about squid game what was
your favorite game what did you like
about it what did you not like about it
talk about all you want in the comment
section
don't go to the comment section if you
don't want spoilers then again by this
time you just watch this video so guys
that warning makes no sense i'm gonna
i'm gonna get out of here i'm gonna
bounce comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you